hợp báo thử kì bộ ngoại sợ cho biết Việt Nam Hoan Ninh các đánh giá khách quan tích cực về kết quả phòng,
chống ngô bản người trong bảo cao năm 2020 của bộ ngoại sợ hoa kỳ lưng quan đến Việt Nam.
Bình năm đang sỉnh 2 đồng vụ chung trình phòng, chống ngô bản người dễ đạn 2020, 2020, 2020, 2020, 2020, 2020, 2020, 2020, 2020,
trong tâm là hoàn thiện pháp lợp, năng cao hiệu quả điều tra, chuy tổ, sách sử, tăng cường, sách định,
vỏ hỗ trợ nạn nhân, kì thời ư phỏ các thiết thức mới, lượt phòng, chống ngô bản người năm 2020,
2020 đạn tạo khuy khổ pháp lý quan trọng cho công tác này.
Bình năm 2020, kể hạt thực hiện thoảng thuận cầu về dí cư hợp pháp, án thuận và chật tự,
nhằm xe dự ngô chưởng dí cư mình bản bảo vệ quyền và lợp ít hợp pháp của mề dí cư,
ngăn chẳng người cơ ngô bản người trong khoản động dí cư cuối tế.
Trên đến tạm đó, bên năm 2020, tâm tiết tục hợp tác và đối thoại với các đối thác đến năng cao hiệu quả phòng,
trong 1 bản người, phục vụ mục tiêu phát triển bình vấn.